el ex-presidente de oro trampa plazo la
rueda de prensa que iba a hacer desde su
mansión de mar a lago en la florida el 6
de enero argumentando que lo hace por
culpa del comité del congreso que
investiga su participación en los
ataques al capitolio el 6 de enero de
2021 su rueda de prensa donde se
esperaba alegar a nuevamente fraude
electoral iba a ser al mismo tiempo que
una oración que se llevaría a cabo en el
capitolio en honor a los policías que
murieron defendiendo la sede del poder
legislativo
rom anunció en el comunicado que hará
entonces una rueda de prensa el 15 de
enero en arizona donde insistirá en el
fraude electoral y a la que según él
acudirán muchas personas sobre la
investigación que adelanta el congreso a
la toma del capitolio el comité
encargado solicitó a sean hannity el
presentador estrella de foxnews y amigo
y asesor del ex presidente de donald
trump que responda a preguntas y que
entregue también información de forma
voluntaria sobre lo que sabía el
presentador con anterioridad al 6 de
enero y que está tallados en algunos
mensajes de texto que compartió con
congresistas republicanos al respecto el
presentador no se ha pronunciado
públicamente y su abogado se limitó a
decir que está evaluando de forma
cercana a la solicitud de información
que le manda el congreso